up next we got Lauren from Nebraska this
is she sounds countess I brother nice Oh
different then we go sup guys this is
Lauren from Nebraska one of my best
friends even about growing up the hair
you know it's getting kind of long here
beautify growing it out I want to get a
mullet you know that Walmart Wolverine
the Louisiana Purchase I feel you baby
yes rocking the Osama bin Laden he lets
cut that dog with a muff tickler oh my
god I don't think about lice for that
white-trash for Rory I'm trying to
figure out how I should convince her
otherwise you know anyways love you guys
let me know what you think Gang Gang
buzz-buzz dude his eyes my brother
[ __ ] I'm in a trance
oh my handsome dude obviously I tell
them in the club oh yeah sure yeah buy
you a salad somewhere I'll buy you a
[ __ ] I'll split a donut with you in
the trunk of your car
yeah this guy definitely easily could be
JonBenet Ramsay and hiding there this
guy dude look at the eyes look at the
skin tone yeah transition baby other
side I could see that man now this guy
look man you got the beard you got that
deal bruh don't let the lady determine
how you want to grow your hair bro you
can't just listen to the lady boss you
around thank you okay we'll give him
some suggestions guys if you give him
some suggestion because you actually
have a moment but this isn't a mullet
first of all there's a long man's male
haircut you mean you know you gotta cut
around the ears though dude yeah I'm
gonna cut around the ears again dude
we're as soon as I get back into the
hair shop and do do what you want okay
yeah I mean right now I feel like you
look like it was like some Rouge on or
some blush on the photo he's got blush
on dude his eyebrows are ridiculously
trimmed
yeah dude are you sure you have a wife
dude yeah dude you sure someone's tell
you not to do it are you looking for
Theo's approval here yeah you're just
looking for two men to talk to you about
your hair
I think you're just fine I think you
already know what you want to do yeah I
did I mean you look very well taken care
of
and at a certain point a beard is just
transporting lice bro okay just
basically you have the Underground
Railroad for head lice hanging under
your chin so if you bring that near a
girl surprise bro they're so dirty [ __ ]
they're so dirty oh dude I was on a bus
in Tucson one time when I was in sure I
don't know some part of school and this
dude had a little a little kind of
holder built into his beard and he had a
[ __ ] little bird in there Oh tight
moved oh that's cool is it now mm-hmm
it was just like a homeless guys bird
eat some easy to get I think got stupid
birds no just bear around Birds
yeah basic Ranbir's berries probably a
nightingale um anyway man I think if you
want to grow a mullet grow a mullet dude
but it's also not even a mullet man you
got it you know you know you it takes
rocks to grow to locs baby you know what
I'm saying you got to have balls to drop
the falls son you just can't do it man
you just can't get that hate crime on
the back of your neck and think
everything's will be all gravy yeah yeah
I would yeah you gotta ease into it bro
just don't shave the sides you look like
a [ __ ] white supremacist what you got
to do is style the top grow the top out
and then get the feel in the back yeah
maybe braid it broke braid at first see
how it goes over at the homies but this
is the rebellion dude this is the
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying you're
growing your own you like this is the
thing your wife says you can't do it and
then you grow it yeah that's what it is
that's that MTV in the early 90s that
rebellion man it's not it's about you
doing you you know what I'm saying it's
not about you being held down by a [ __ ]
barber with a [ __ ] a 1 into a 2 with
the [ __ ] [ __ ] fade you know and he
gots the [ __ ] in there and the
magazines and all of that and [ __ ]
here's the other thing though it's also
the first step to transition it yeah so
if you're gonna shave the sighs leave
the back next thing you know you got
tits transient so you know put a little
Rouge on the lips next thing you know
you got some mascara on next you know
you're wearing your wife's skirt you
know I'm say hey Lee yeah that's how it
starts with mullets bro no I've never
seen any that all I've seen is a sheer
warrior [ __ ] grow it on my heart
that's all I've seen so you grow the
hair first and the rest you will follow
son yeah maybe they letting your wife
determine what you [ __ ] hang you
don't come out of here
you know what we better get a video next
week with you a little [ __ ] mullet
have you know courage boy god damn
brother you know courage boy you know
what ethnicity she is though because if
she's Mexican they're [ __ ] spicy man
she's Puerto Rican I get it bro I'll
send you to be one of the Lord Frey's
daughters dude out there you better look
like [ __ ] Dermer yeah gir next week
bro yeah yeah yeah Jesus Christ and
obviously that is the name that had burn
and drop out of school when Jaromir Jagr
you know you know that famous hockey
players here for the Pittsburgh Bing oh
[ __ ] don't touch me dude you're
disgusting grow your [ __ ] out don't ask
your wife if you can plant Jennison
y'all do it and when you come home say
shut up that's God's backyard brother
and he gave it Heatley he lent you a
little bit you're just sharecropping so
won't you ask God what he wants you to
do sorry man I'm a little fired up and
no you should be bro you should be but
it is that's what's goin on man
a real man would grow it out dude you
know remember even ask ya better see a
video next week with you the full-blown
[ __ ] hillbilly mullet brah
yeah broccolini
get your life together touch me bro I'm
not touching